at this camp an hour outside of rome
more than a thousand afghan refugees are
starting a new life
now far from the country they called
home many of them like this man felt
they had no choice but to flee
i work with italian and afghan military
so i was a target for the taliban
he like others we spoke to asked us not
to show his face out of fear for loved
ones back in
afghanistan i am happy to be here but i
am extremely worried about my family
i haven't been able to contact them for
seven days i don't know how they're
doing or where they are
it's a story repeated here among those
who worked with italian or other
international forces during the war as
the taliban closed in they rushed to
kabul airport some lost family in the
chaotic rush to escape and haven't seen
them since
one refugee we met served as a policeman
in the former government he told us he
felt particularly at risk of taliban
retribution since august 14th nearly 5
000 afghan refugees have arrived in
italy the largest number of any european
union country i feel safe here
but i'm a bit worried about
the my future how can i organize
everything how how can i continue to
my higher education those running the
camp are trying to address such concerns
of course they want to know about their
future the process of inclusion in our
country which steps now they are going
to do in uh to be included in our
society about the
the schools for the children
the job
and all this of course we cannot give an
answer to all of these questions but to
engage explaining the process step by
step this camp run by the italian red
cross is the largest processing center
for the refugees in italy more than 1300
afghan evacuees have been sheltered here
temporarily as they await longer term
placements after being screened for
covet 19 many received vaccinations
after being processed here the evacuees
are then taken by bus to other shelters
and hotels across italy
officials hope to resettle everyone at
this camp by friday the first step in
helping these refugees rebuild their
lives in a new country adam rainey al
jazeera avezano italy